Now…
-…for the first time in the tent…
-That's deafening.
…it's Back to School Week.
A long time ago.
It's black and white for me.
The bakers flap under pressure
in the Signature…
Devastated.
…go back to basics in the Technical…
We're just not built
like old-school lunch ladies.
…before a summer fête finale
in the Showstopper.
-But who will make the grade?
-That takes me back, Prue.
-And who…
-Broken it.
…will flunk out?
No!
-See me at the end of class.
-Sorry, sir.
I just like to get things right, so…
I'm back for week four!
I'm just so happy.
I want to show Paul and Prue
my skills again.
I am glad that I'm baking
for Back to School Week
and not actually going back to school.
Good golly, I don't need to do that again.
I'm so gassed to go back to school.
I can't wait.
I think it will be a fun week.
Yeah, haven't done
that much homework this week.
I'm feeling like there's a medium chance
that I'm gonna get expelled.
Suspended, if nothing else.
-Morning, bakers.
-Morning.
Er, excuse me.
I expect you all to say,
"Good morning, Miss Hammond".
Good morning, bakers.
Good morning, Miss Hammond.
That's better, isn't it, Mr Fielding?
The reason that Alison
is behaving like Miss Trunchbull
is 'cause we're gonna be taking you
back to your school days.
For your first school-time bake,
Miss Leith and Miss Hollywood
would love you to…
…to make a batch
of 12 identical flapjacks.
Your flapjacks will need
the classic oaty base,
but also an extra filling or topping.
-You've got two hours.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
Quite looking forward to it.
I actually forgot
how much I like flapjacks.
I did eat them at school,
but it's not something I have often.
They make me a bit bloated normally, so…
This is Back to School Week.
It's all about reinventing bakes
that you had at school,
only this time,
making them really, really good.
This golden syrup is gonna get messy.
It's a flapjack. It's just full of sugar
and predominantly golden syrup.
And so, it'll be interesting to see
how the bakers interpret the sugar levels.
I've taken out the golden syrup
and then replaced it
with a red wine reduction.
We want a very special flapjack,
but I think you have to be careful
with the adding of new flavours
because you don't want
to overpower the oats.
Milk time, students!
Make sure you stay hydrated.
Right, good girl.
Look, this one's drinking her milk there.
We're really asking the bakers
to push the boat out
and create a little bit of school magic.
Morning, Tom.
-Hello, Tom.
-Morning.
Right, Tom,
tell us all about your flapjack.
Today I'm making apple crumble flapjack,
but this is kind of pushing the brief
in terms of what a flapjack is.
So it should look like
the top half of an apple,
and then when you slice it open,
you're like, "Oh, there's a flapjack
hiding inside there".
Aiming for an A-star,
Tom's flamboyant flapjacks
will be surrounded by apple purée
and custard fillings,
before being encased in a white chocolate
apple-shaped shell.
-Wow. Okay.
-Wow. Well, Tom, that is ambitious.
-Have you practiced this?
-Kind of.
You're supposed to come to school
ready for the exam.
Well, I did the homework,
and then I thought I could do it
a little better so…
You're answering back.
He's pushing for excellence.
He's pushing for detention,
that's what he's pushing for.
To avoid any disciplinary issues
of their own…
So these are Irish oats, obviously.
It's just the ones I had in the house.
…choosing the right oats is crucial.
Do you want it
to kind of be dense, more cakey?
Do you want it to have a bite?
Do you want that texture?
But striking the right balance…
Half rolled oats and half porridge oats.
…is entirely up to the bakers.
So these are rolled oats
'cause I'm doing a carrot cake recipe
but just replacing the flour with oats.
When I was young, I really wasn't
that bothered about flapjacks,
but I really like carrot cake,
so I thought I'll make
carrot cake-flavoured flapjacks.
Toby's flapjacks
will be individually moulded
to resemble a slice of carrot cake,
and topped with cream cheese icing.
Time for your milk.
Well, thank you very much for the offer,
but I'm actually lactose intolerant,
so unless you wanna have
a gassy afternoon…
-Okay. I'll leave that then. Laters.
-Okay, cheers.
Let's get her in.
To avoid upsetting Paul and Prue…
Pear is a naturally wet fruit.
Hopefully we'll be all right.
…the bakers must pack their flapjacks
with flavour
without compromising the consistency.
I'm putting in
some very ripe banana into it.
So these are
banana bread-inspired flapjacks.
It's gonna be unusual, this.
Have you given it to anybody?
My partner took it
to her pole dancing class--
Her pole dancing class.
Yeah.
And they all loved it.
Was Prue in there?
Hoping to spin his way into pole position,
lain's banana bread flapjacks
will be covered in layers of walnut paste,
white chocolate honey ganache
and caramelised banana.
Do you miss school?
I like designated time to have fun.
-I never play any more.
-Oh, go on then.
-I never climb stuff.
-You've got two minutes. Off you go.
Go and have a play, go on.
-Yes, lain! Yes, lain!
-There.
-Go and have a little play. Go on.
-Oh.
This is great! See you, guys.
How did he do this?
Someone wanna play with me?
Guys!
But lain's not the only one…
Does no one wanna play?
…recapturing their youth.
So I'm gonna put in
freeze-dried raspberries.
My great-aunt,
she'd always have a tinful of flapjacks
and we'd always go raspberry picking,
fruit picking in the summer.
Jasmine's soft raspberry flapjack
will be covered
in a rich chocolate ganache
and topped with a firm tempered chocolate.
So when you cut through,
it'll be like hard, soft
and then the flapjack.
But in practice,
I've never managed to do it in time,
so I just need to get them
in and out ASAP.
But while some bakers
are recreating
their favourite childhood flavours…
The pumpkin seeds add a bit of a crunch.
Very sophisticated.
…Aaron's aiming for something
a little more mature.
So my flapjacks are Earl Grey,
whipped ganache and lemon jam.
The Earl Grey isn't a dominant flavour,
it's like a bridge.
Go on, bridge between what?
-Between the lemon and…
-Yeah.
…the rest of it.
No.
What you need to do is build a bridge
between your bake and Paul's hand.
Aaron's flapjacks
are dedicated to his friend Latifa,
who can't get enough of his lemon jam.
He's hoping the judges will be
just as convinced with his flavours.
Are you gonna be head boy today?
Probably.
I don't know, actually.
He didn't sound that enthused
about my flavours, so possibly not.
Don't let him psych you out.
Don't let Mr Hollywood psych you out.
Aaron may be aiming
for a grown-up flapjack…
I use pecan nuts and cherries
and a bit of amaretto.
…but Nataliia's will be
strictly adults-only.
Not for school. The kids will be drunk.
Her boozy flapjacks
might not get past the school gate,
but Nataliia's been thrown
back into the classroom,
learning to make flapjacks
for the first time.
Do you not have flapjacks in Ukraine?
No, absolutely not.
-You should take them over there.
-Yeah.
You could start
your own flapjack business.
Smart.
It's time to get this in the tin
and get that in the oven.
I am using individual moulds.
If I'm not meticulous with this bit now,
when I try and take the moulds off,
they will fall apart.
In they go.
I'll bake the flapjacks
for around 15 minutes.
I really don't wanna overbake them.
While overbaking will result
in a tougher texture…
Twenty-three minutes or so.
It's all based on vibes.
…underbaking will leave them
too soft and claggy to eat.
There we go,
and I'll start that for 20 minutes.
But while everyone else
has begun baking their flapjacks…
Shortbread's in and then get my jam done.
Start my flapjack.
…Lesley's yet to start hers.
I'm making a cherry Bakewell flapjack
with a shortbread base.
Inspired by
her neighbour Dan's favourite treat,
Lesley's Bakewell flapjacks will feature
a shortbread base, a layer of cherry jam,
and finished off with glacé cherries.
And you bake the whole thing together?
Doing it separate,
because in practice I tried it
and the shortbread didn't cook underneath.
-Bake.
-Sorry, sir.
-Hundred lines. It's "bake" not "cook".
-Bake.
See me at the end of class for lines.
Yes, okay.
I'm in trouble. I've not even started yet.
That's deafening.
-Bakers, you are halfway through!
-Here we go.
Keep going,
or there's detention with Mr Hollywood.
Miss Hollywood.
Come on. Bake quicker!
If producing 12 flawless flapjacks
wasn't challenging enough…
I'm gonna start caramelising
some of these bananes.
…before the end of class bell rings…
This is gonna be a lumpy custard
like back at school,
with skin on top that they're gonna
have to peel off nicely.
…the bakers still need to make
their delicate decorations…
I'm gonna put a candied hazelnut
on top of each one.
…and tantalising toppings.
So I'm starting my cherry jam.
On the way to school,
I used to love a coconut chocolate bar.
I used to buy the two-pack
'cause I loved them that much.
So I want this to be a cherry version
of that chocolate bar.
Nadia's hoping to recreate
her favourite childhood treat
by coating her coconut flapjack
and cherry jam
with a perfectly tempered chocolate top.
So what temperature are you taking it to,
to temper?
I had a little piece of paper--
-You're cheating.
-I'm not--
You're cheating in class
and I think this is outrageous.
She might as well write it
on the back of her hand.
While Nadia still has some studying to do,
Jessika's come prepared.
So I've done a lot of homework
for Back to School Week.
So I've decided that it's gonna have
red wine, poached pears,
stem ginger and dark chocolate ganache.
So it's gonna be like a mouthful.
Inspired by her close friend
Audrey's favourite flavours,
chocolate and wine,
Jessika's flapjacks will be finished off
with poached pears.
Are you gonna be top of the class today?
I don't know, but I just don't wanna be
excluded from school.
I don't wanna go home.
Did you think you was going last week?
-I was so shocked when Pui Man left.
-You were shocked. See?
-You never know who's going, do ya?
-Never know.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
Half an hour.
-Cheers.
-Cheers, babs.
White Russian.
Need to make sure my jam's spread out,
and then it's all going in the oven.
While Lesley's flapjack
is yet to go in the oven…
Flappy jays.
…the rest of the bakers
are ready to come out of theirs.
So, there we go.
Do you know what? We're done.
The edges are nice and brown,
and it's got a nice even colour.
Hallelujah!
Flapjacks are baked,
so I feel like I'm in good time.
Going back in the oven.
Fingers crossed they'll cool in time.
I'm not confident.
Just a waiting game really.
Try and cool it.
Everything here needs to be cool
by the time it goes
in the white chocolate mould.
I'd be lying if I said I wasn't nervous.
Twelve identical flapjacks.
Normally, I'd just do it by eye.
Ooh, that was not a straight line.
With my wee back-to-school ruler.
You've got to be very precise,
otherwise you get shouted at
by the teachers.
That's how they're supposed to come out.
Look at that. Look.
Holding its structure well.
No!
I've broken it.
Right, we've got 16 out. That's good news.
Cut like this, and I have my 12 flapjack.
Little school sandwiches.
Bakers, you have 15 minutes left.
I'm gonna temper my dark chocolate now.
So let me just get
my little piece of paper.
Just tempering some chocolate.
It set really quickly,
which is a good sign.
Please set.
I'm suddenly very rushy feeling.
-I feel like you've got a lot to do.
-I have so much to do!
If you pull this off, I feel like
you could be in Handshake City.
The icing's got to be great,
because they're quite basic.
The chocolate's just not setting.
Oh, Mother.
I'm not sure that it's gonna cool in time.
I'm just gonna have to cut it.
-How's it going?
-Not very well.
Oh, no, don't say that.
It's still warm. It's just not setting.
-Well, look, you're still smiling.
-Yeah.
It's only first lesson. It's a long day.
This is just to cover the bases.
Clock is ticking.
How long have we got?
You've got one minute left, bakers.
Ugh. Oh, this is gutting.
I've totally run out of time here.
Tempered chocolate has tempered and set.
Oh, devastated.
I want it to look neat.
Oh, it's not even staying on. So sad.
They don't look great.
I'm gonna get a detention, definitely.
I'm not gonna
be able to get the tops on. Ugh! No!
Bakers, your time is up.
Ta-da!
We did it.
Well done, bakers. Put your pens down.
I ran out of time.
-Absolutely smashed it.
-They are beautiful.
Mine look dreadful.
I'm devastated.
My chocolate didn't set.
It's judgement time
for the bakers' flapjacks.
-Hello, Tom.
-Hello.
Hi, Tom.
Right, Tom,
tell us all about your… flapjacks?
My abstract apples.
It looks more like an apple
with the stalk coming out.
-Yes, you needed the stalk.
-Yeah, I think you needed that.
It's very clever, Tom.
It just absolutely says apple crumble.
I really love it. I really do. It's great.
I think it is so clever.
We said we didn't want a boring flapjack.
-Well done.
-Amazing.
I love the intricacy of the decoration.
I think they look neat as a pin.
I love the chewiness. It's not too sweet.
Chewiness, check, texture, check,
and flavour, check.
-So, I think you've ticked all the boxes.
-Thank you.
Very good.
Caramelised banana slices on the top.
Makes my mouth water.
You certainly get the banana.
Less so the walnuts.
It's a bit soft.
A little bit longer,
I would have put in the oven.
I was aiming for
a soft banana bread-esque.
Oh, is that what you were going for?
I'm so sorry.
-Come on.
-I think it's excellent.
Thank you. Oh, there we go.
-We asked for flapjacks.
-Yeah.
It's just slightly underbaked.
They've been cut a bit oddly,
haven't they?
Not very neat.
I think it's really difficult
to cut them into triangles.
-They're very chewy.
-Yeah.
The chocolate ganache
is the overpowering flavour.
Mm-hmm.
It's a bit dry,
but it's the texture for me.
The size difference so dramatic.
'Cause I couldn't see anything
'cause the chocolate
wasn't set on the top.
There's a lot of chocolate
on the top of that,
-which is why it didn't set.
-Yeah.
I'm not getting a huge amount of coconut
because what's dominating
is the half-inch of chocolate.
I agree. Too much chocolate.
-The cherry is perfect.
-Mm.
-I think they look lovely.
-They really do look great.
Mm. The spice level with the cinnamon,
it's quite high.
I like it,
but I wanted that carrot cake taste.
I added a tiny bit more in today
than I normally do.
It's a shame,
because texture I thought was great.
-Thank you, Toby.
-Thank you.
What made you put more cinnamon in?
Last week, I put a little bit extra in,
and they loved it,
so I thought, this week, I'll do the same.
-Whack a little bit extra in.
-Oh, man.
-It was too much.
-Gutted.
So interesting and different.
I like that.
It cuts neatly, doesn't it?
It does. Hmm.
I like the flavour. The texture,
for me, is a little too gluey.
Okay.
-It might be the pear.
-Okay.
It's really softened up
the flapjack itself.
Would it have helped
if I added more jumbo oats for the crunch?
Yeah, probably.
When I actually added the ratio,
I reduced the jumbo oats.
Thinking that that
would have been a better idea, but…
-Thank you.
Thank you.
Damn. Leave the recipe as it is.
I know. Same thing.
I love the decoration.
I think it looks beautiful, really neat.
I'm dying to see what it tastes like.
-That's delicious.
-Oh, my God!
The lemon gives it such a lift.
I can get the Earl Grey.
-I think you've done a really good job.
-Aw, thank you so much.
-I love it.
-Oh, really? Oh, my gosh!
Absolutely, yeah.
Yeah, it's a triumph. Well done.
Thank you.
Yes!
Well done. I'll have a bit of that.
Gassed.
My cheeks.
Didn't cool down quite well enough to cut.
I was a bit worried about
the timing with this.
I think doing the shortbread
and the flapjack,
-it's all about the cooling.
-Mmm.
Mmm.
It's a real Bakewell flavour.
I think it's a little too sweet for me
because the icing is thick.
-Glacé cherries are really sweet.
-Mm. Yeah.
Huge mistake
putting the shortbread on the base.
-It's not your finest hour, yeah.
-No, it isn't.
See me, Lesley.
Okay.
Paul shouted out
I need to go and see him afterwards.
Just go and sit in the corner now,
shall I?
That task is proof
that you need to do your homework
and you need to practise
because I was a hairline away
from that looking so bad.
Less chocolate. If I could go back,
I would, but I can't,
so I've just got to
take it on the shoulders
and look forward to the old Technical now.
I don't know if I should say,
"Look forward to it", but…
The bakers were able to revise
their flapjack recipes,
but in the Technical challenge,
they have no idea
what old-school bake they face.
Bakers, it is time
for your Technical challenge,
and this one has been set by Miss Leith.
If you mess this Technical up,
it will be going on your permanent record.
Now, Miss Leith,
have you got any words of wisdom?
Prepare yourself
to do a lot of elbow grease.
Hmm.
As always, this challenge is judged blind,
so, Paul and Prue,
you may now leave the tent.
Thank you so much.
So, for your Technical challenge,
Prue would love you to recreate
that fondly remembered classic,
school cake.
Your school cake
must consist of vanilla sponge,
white glacé icing,
and then finished with sprinkles.
And with a nice jug of hot custard.
It all sounds quite simple,
but there is a twist.
Headmistress Leith is demanding
that you make everything from scratch.
Even the sprinkles.
Headmistress also stripped down
your working areas
and kept it to the bare baking essentials.
-You've got two hours.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake.
Let's do this.
Oh, my gosh!
Never in my life had school cake.
I just thought a school cake
would be too basic.
Which is why we have to make
everything from scratch.
So, Prue, sponge and custard.
What a great Technical challenge this is.
One of my favourites.
What's gonna make this tricky
for our bakers?
The bakers have to do
everything from scratch
and with no modern equipment.
So, they've got to beat the sugar
and butter by hand.
If they don't beat that really well,
they won't get the rise.
How are they gonna do
these sprinkles then?
To make the sprinkles,
they have to pipe the lines,
wait till they're absolutely set,
chop them into tiny little sprinkles,
and scatter them on top of their icing
when it's still wet.
And then we've asked them
to make lump-free custard.
This looks great!
That sweetness from the icing
is just about right.
The sponge is moist,
but with that gorgeous custard,
that's fantastic.
Almost anything tastes good with custard,
but this is the best.
Right. "Make the sponge batter by hand."
And for the sponge ingredients,
there are no weights.
I put 300 grammes of sugar, 400 of flour.
At home, I do similar quantities of this.
It's basically just a vanilla sponge cake.
Just creaming the butter
and sugar together.
And I want to get it fairly light.
If the bakers don't cream
the butter and sugar thoroughly…
-It's like having a workout.
-…the mix will lack air…
My arm's hurting already.
…essential for giving their sponges
the right rise and light, fluffy texture.
We're just not built
like old-school lunch ladies.
They can mix by arm for hours.
That looks like it's quite a feat,
to stir that.
Right? You want to give it a go?
Yeah, it's not for me.
It's not for me.
I'm like Oscar Wilde. That's not for me.
Oh, ambulance!
It's lumpy.
Not the best,
but that's what I'm going with.
Hopefully, it'll be fine.
Now I'm just adding the eggs in
one at a time.
Oh, yeah. That's the stuff.
Once I add the baking powder
and the flour,
should start coming together better.
The baking powder's a tricky one.
Got about 5%, and I'm hoping that's right.
Wanna have like a flat sponge.
I've done a teaspoon per 100 grammes.
But I have no idea
whether that's right or not.
Right, I think that'll have to do.
I bet you was a good boy at school,
weren't you?
I was the one who did too much talking.
-All the time.
-You like a bit of… A gossip?
-Yeah.
-What do you know about this lot?
I've heard that Aaron is waiting
for Paul Hollywood
to call him a naughty boy.
Really?
That's actually me.
I just wanna get my cake in the oven.
See what happens.
I'm gonna go for 170,
20 minutes, and check it.
Twenty minutes.
Probably gonna take like 25 minutes.
It's a pretty chunky cake.
-Is that going in the oven?
-Bless this cake for me.
-Thank you.
-Yes, blessed.
It's gonna win.
It's gonna get a handshake.
If it fails, it's your fault.
I'm not sure
my blessing is worth anything.
I forgot vanilla.
I'm going rogue.
Got that just in time.
Hope that doesn't affect the bake.
Shouldn't do.
I've made this.
-Oh my God, I love it.
-Choose a colour.
-Green.
-Green. G-R-E-E-N.
-Choose a number.
-Four.
One, two, three, four.
Three.
-Sure?
-Yeah.
"Halfway through." Oh, amazing.
Bakers, you are halfway through!
-You can have it.
-Thank you.
Took me all day.
That mean we're going out now?
-Yeah, we are. Absolutely.
-Right.
It just says, "Make the sprinkles".
But how are you gonna make
the little sprinkle people?
Got no idea.
Prue's jewellery. Put it in a blender.
Mixing together 60 grammes
of pasteurised egg whites.
I've done 300 grammes of icing sugar.
Not sure what the texture's
supposed to be.
I've done four out of the five colours
so far, so I just gotta do this last one.
Now we need to make our piping bags.
Not sure how to do it.
Doing origami now.
Has anyone figured this part out yet?
No.
And then does that fold in?
Yeah, like that.
Okay. Ooh.
Just gonna see if this works.
I'm gonna pipe the sprinkles in lines.
My red one.
I thought sprinkles were dots.
I don't trust dots.
Little, little, little lines.
-This is gonna take me a year.
-Bit of yellow.
Something tells me this isn't the method.
We've made it. Oops.
We're going lines.
I've given up on the dots.
I guess it'll dry out
and then you can break it up.
This is pants.
They're not even gonna look the same.
Have you ever made sprinkles?
Paul Hollywood cries sprinkles.
I collect them in a tub.
This should just be the challenge,
make sprinkles.
"You will be making 1,474 sprinkles."
Bakers, you have half an hour left!
So proud of these kids.
-So proud.
-All of them. So proud of them.
Maybe I will, maybe I won't.
Think it might be ready to come out.
You know what? She's coming out.
I'm actually really happy
with that, I think.
I reckon it's about five minutes away.
The middle still needs a bit of cooking.
Ooh, we've got some big sinkage,
big sinkage on the cake.
It's cooked, but I think it's collapsed
because there's too much
baking powder in it.
"Make the sprinkles, leave them to set
in the residual heat of the oven."
What does "residual" mean?
Does it mean
like the table with the door open,
like once the cake's out? Residual?
Oh, it's a bit hot in here, babes.
What's going on?
-It's so hot.
-Bit of heat going on.
-Sorry.
-Oh, my God. I'm getting a hot flush.
Thought I was going through menopause.
This is so cool. Look at that. Look.
And then it just breaks up.
-"Number seven, make the custard."
-I think it's time to make some custard.
They've actually been quite nice to us.
They have given us ingredients.
I've made custard before.
I'm not that worried about it.
I think I need to make mine thicker.
I don't wanna step away from my custard.
It'll curdle or split
or do something horrible.
Stick a spoon in, draw a line,
holds a line, done.
Children, you have 15 minutes left.
"Coat the top of the cake,
decorating with the sprinkles."
Think it may be a thin layer of icing.
Little bit messy.
Oh, they're not sticking.
It's set,
so I just need to push them in a bit.
I don't like any of those
even-looking sprinkles.
Look at that. That's art.
-Is it Jackson Pollock?
-It's a Picasso.
"Slice the cake into 16
and serve along with a jug of custard."
Find the centre. There.
It's a four by four, isn't it?
I've a bachelor's in a science.
Feels like I should be good at maths.
Oh, I've done it wrong, haven't I?
I've got 15 instead of 16
'cause I can't do maths.
Bakers, you only have one minute left!
Oh, God. I've already made a mess.
Try not to panic.
I'm actually not mad.
Oh.
Why are these ones so small?
Some of them are a bit skew-whiff.
Looks like a school cake.
Bakers, your time is up.
Please bring your school cakes
and place them
behind your beautiful photos.
Oh, dear.
Oh, look at them!
-Oh, yours so nice.
-That was hard.
Paul and Prue
are expecting 16 school cakes
with a light moist sponge, neat icing,
and handmade colourful sprinkles,
served with a jug of delicious custard.
Could we all stand
for Miss Leith and Mr Hollywood?
Okay, Prue,
do you wanna start with this one?
The icing on this
doesn't look too bad in places.
Dropped a bit here.
They've struggled with the bake
in the middle of the tray perhaps.
But the sprinkles are there.
-Sponge is nice, actually.
-Custard's got too much vanilla in it.
But it's a good consistency.
This is a bit loud,
and they're all over the place.
And again, some of them
are better risen than others.
That cake's quite nice.
It's a bit dense.
Custard's got a couple of lumps in.
These look beautiful.
Lovely height. Nice and even.
-It's good cake. Good sprinkles.
-Mm.
Good icing.
Custard just needs
to be thickened slightly.
These haven't risen enough.
Yeah, they're all different sizes,
not consistent at all. Right.
Tastes all right, though.
-It's good cake. Tastes nice.
-Mm.
That's slightly split, isn't it?
Oh, dear. What have we here?
Icing's all poured over the edge.
The sprinkles are sort of
all over the place as well.
-It's a bit overbaked.
-It's quite dry.
So it's overbaked and the icing is…
Stop it.
Custard's all right.
Right, these are very small.
It's got a bit of height on one side.
Those two have got all the sprinkles.
This one's got practically none.
-Cake's a little dry.
-It's because it's dense.
How's the custard?
Nice and smooth.
Now this one,
it's all different shapes again.
It should be easy
to get them all the same size.
Mainly, my complaint about this
is unevenness.
These sprinkles
on the top are interesting.
It's quite doughy there. See.
Probably the weight of the icing,
to be honest.
Should be quite a light icing.
The cake is quite good.
The cake's all right.
Custard's good.
These look good.
They're quite even, nice height.
Good sprinkles.
-That's good.
-Hang on a minute.
Custard's very good.
That takes me back, Prue.
Mmm. Delicious.
The judges will now
rank the school cakes from worst to best.
In ninth place, we have this one.
Nadia, the cake is overbaked,
you're short of one,
and the custard is slightly curdled.
-Not your best effort.
-No.
In the eighth spot, we have this one.
Nataliia, too heavy on the icing.
It destroyed the sponge.
In seventh spot is Jessika,
Tom is sixth, Lesley fifth,
Toby fourth, and Iain takes third.
In second spot, we have…
This one. Aaron, pretty good, these.
It just came down to the overall neatness,
but they were a good effort.
Which means that this is the winner.
Who is that?
Jasmine, that is a beautiful cake.
Perfectly risen,
your sprinkles are excellent.
-Well done.
-Thank you.
What? I actually can't believe it.
They liked it.
And they went back for more.
I'm last today. I can't believe
I couldn't get a school cake right.
I make it all the time.
But, I mean,
Paul was tapping on it, it was rock solid.
I wanted to do better than seventh,
so I'm a little bit disappointed,
but I think I'm ready for tomorrow.
Let's go.
Don't know about you, Noel,
but I've loved going back to school,
especially with Mr Hollywood
and Miss Leith.
-Miss Hollywood.
-What do you reckon?
I think it's been very good fun.
And the baking has been absolutely lovely.
-Aaron's Signature. It was fantastic.
-Yeah.
He's having a really good week, isn't he?
Second in the Technical.
Yeah. And Jasmine, as always,
very near the top, if not at the top.
I would say Toby probably
could join for Star Baker.
It depends how he gets on today.
Who do you think's not doing so well?
Well, Nadia. Straight away, Nadia.
I think Jessika's down there.
-Nataliia.
-Nataliia's down there.
I met a lot of them last night
'cause they were all in detention.
So I get that…
Did you have the cane out?
I spoke to the parents.
They're gonna be all right for today.
Hello, bakers.
It's time for your back-to-school
Showstopper challenge.
But before we start,
Noel, what was you like at school?
I was pretty good, actually.
I was second from top in my class.
-Who was first?
-It was my brother.
Just the two of us, actually.
We were home-schooled.
So, for your Showstopper challenge,
the judges would love you to bake
a spectacular summer fête stall display.
Now the judges will be looking
for an array of decorative themed treats
that really capture the spirit
of the summer school fête.
Your display should have
at least one large bake
and two batches of 12 smaller ones.
-You have four and a half hours.
-On your marks.
-Get set.
-Bake!
My primary school
had an amazing school fair.
I always got so competitive
at like hook-a-duck, quoits.
I always used to head to the bake stall.
Used to love it.
I always do the tombola
at the kids' school fairs
'cause I wanna win some wine.
Whoo. Whoo!
Straight in. Knock one back.
The bakers' Showstopper challenge,
it's gonna be a tricky one.
We're asking them to reproduce
a traditional school summer fête in bakes.
So I'm starting with the cake.
It's quite hefty.
I'll get that out of the way first.
This is a demanding challenge.
We want them to display at least
three different baking disciplines,
and the difficulty with that
is about timing.
This is where we have to have
a bit of a balancing act.
I've never had three things
on the go at once.
The hardest part of multi-baking
is different rising temperatures,
different oven temperatures.
They could go wrong in every single area.
It's a very busy bench today.
You have to be a real artist
and I think have a great baking flair
to produce something magical,
which we expect today.
-Morning, Toby.
-Hi, Toby.
Tell us about your cake stall.
So I'm going to do
a lemon and blueberry cake
-decorated as a hook-a-duck game.
-Ooh.
And I'm gonna do
some choux bun tennis balls
and a version of my childhood
favourite sandwich after school,
chicken instant noodle sandwiches.
-Ugh!
-Your what?
Luckily for Paul and Prue,
Toby's childhood sandwiches
have matured into Parmesan biscuits
filled with chicken pâté and ricotta.
He's also serving choux bun tennis balls
filled with strawberry cream,
alongside his school fête centrepiece,
a blueberry and lemon hook-a-duck cake.
-And do we win a prize if we hook a duck?
-You can win the hamper.
Everything's labelled
so you know what's going on.
Lovely.
Let's see
what she's going home with tonight.
Well, I'm very competitive.
-Me too.
-So you may not win.
Toby's hook-a-duck cake
will be facing some competition
of its own.
This is my cake
and this is gonna make the swimming pool
which I'll put my ducks in
for hook-a-duck.
Jasmine's orange and elderflower
hook-a-duck cake
will be joined by two more
classic school fête games,
and she's hoping
her rosemary pretzel quoits
and raspberry jam hopscotch biscuits
will be enough to take home
the grand prize once again.
Who was Star Baker last week?
I don't know, I'm just saying.
If you get two in a row,
everyone's gonna go, "Oh, wow!"
Well, I think I'm gonna go, "Argh!"
Everyone'll be a bit like, "Oh!"
But Toby and Jasmine
aren't the only ones
hoping to make a splash.
I think a few people are doing it.
We're going the hook-a-duck game.
Yeah.
That's the cake, and then,
biology was probably
the only subject I really liked at school,
so I am doing
little petri dish crème brûlées
that will have these bacterial growthy
sugar circles on the top.
And then we have the coconut shy.
Your eyes lit up then, Prue.
Complicated, as always.
Tom's ambitious display includes
today's third hook-a-duck centrepiece,
a red velvet cake
filled with cream cheese buttercream.
It's served alongside
vanilla crème brûlée petri dishes
and chocolate coconuts
filled with coconut mousse.
And he's hoping this fête
goes better than the last one he attended.
Last year, my dad was officially
made chairman of the local village fête.
He got me to do face painting,
and the first guy that sat down
was this bald guy who was like,
"Can you make me a tiger?"
And I started painting him
without looking at a photo of a tiger,
and he just came out
looking like a basketball,
and I was very confused.
But hopefully,
my baking is better than my face painting
and we will get somewhere today.
To stand out
at today's back-to-school fête…
A raspberry and vanilla funfetti cake.
…the bakers must pack their cakes
with irresistible flavours and textures.
Zest of four lemons went in.
I want them to taste the lemon.
But Lesley's hoping
to trick the judges' tastebuds.
I am making an illusion bake.
It's gonna look like a meat pie.
So, it's gonna be sweet,
but it looks savoury.
-Do you enjoy this type of baking?
-I love it.
I've made the pie before.
'Cause my dad loved meat pie,
so I made him pie and chips and peas
and all that.
Are we getting the chips and peas?
No. Just the pie.
Lesley's giant
coffee and walnut pie illusion cake
filled with brownies instead of beef
will take centre stage
in her 1970s display,
accompanied by apple shortbread biscuits
and rainbow meringue lollies,
two favourites from her school days.
-It's a long time ago for us, innit?
-It is, yeah.
-1975.
-I know.
-It's black and white for me.
-Yeah.
Sepia.
Oh, my God!
But Lesley's '70s school fête
won't be the oldest in the tent.
My name of my bake
is "Prehistoric Pantry",
so hopefully I'm gonna make
a 3-D dinosaur coming out of a book.
Jessika's dino Derek
will spring from the pages
of her stout cake book,
while the rest of her prehistoric pastries
include marshmallow and
raspberry jam-filled footprint biscuits
and chocolate dinosaur eggs
with a chai-spiced ganache.
This is my massive stout cake.
And it is about to go in the oven.
I hope it's okay.
The bigger the cake…
Just need to get this cake in ASAP.
…the longer it'll take to bake.
I'm gonna put it into four different tins.
Otherwise,
it's a 45-minute bake in a big tin
and I don't have time for that.
And with additional elements
also needing the oven…
Gonna just keep ploughing through my list.
Hopefully get it all done on time.
…staying on schedule is crucial.
When we've got so many elements to do,
no matter what, you've gotta keep going.
But as the only baker
not using cake for their centrepiece…
So I'm making a giant macaron stopwatch.
It's huge.
…Aaron will have
to keep an eye on the time.
I'm conscious
that nothing's been in the oven yet.
These have gotta wait for 30 minutes
till I can get a skin so I can bake them.
But you're in
a good position though, aren't ya?
Your Signature was good, Technical good.
I've never held a man
while he makes a macaron before.
-How was it for ya?
-It was beautiful.
Aaron's massive macaron stopwatch
will feature layers of orange caramel
and hazelnut mousse.
Alongside, he'll serve up
peach cream-filled cricket balls
and iced bun tennis balls.
I've never actually been to a school fête.
We used to have sports days,
so I've done sports-inspired bakes.
Go, go, go.
But Aaron's not the only baker
facing their first school fête.
'Cause you've never even seen a fête.
No. I've seen the fighting in the UK.
Oh, you have seen a fête.
Two girls like… on the streets, like…
No, we're not talking about a fight.
Talking about a fête.
Oh, my gosh. I don't understand nothing.
Help me.
Nataliia's come well prepared
for her first school fête
with a citrus curd-filled backpack cake,
shortbread biscuit pencils
and glazed apples
filled with apple mousse and jam.
It takes a long time to set.
It must be completely frozen.
Whether it's setting mousse…
So, this is the coconut mousse,
and then these will go
straight into the freezer.
…making dough…
So now I'm gonna prove this.
I'm gonna put it in the proving drawer.
…brownies…
Who don't like a brownie?
…or biscuits…
Cutting up my biscuit dough
to make dinosaur feet.
…Paul and Prue have demanded
the bakers to include
at least three distinct
baking disciplines in their displays.
Choux bun time. The flick is essential.
But if that wasn't challenging enough,
Nadia's taking it one step further.
I'm proving my doughnut dough
'cause that's gonna take the longest.
'Cause I'm actually doing
four different things,
so I really wanna try
and get everything done in the time.
In a bid to stay in the competition,
Nadia's going all out
with a giant vanilla cupcake
topped with strawberry meringue,
shortbread biscuits with lemon curd dip,
brownie burgers
and strawberry-glazed doughnuts.
Listen, you've got it all
to play for today.
It's all down to you.
You've got children at school.
-Do they ever have school fêtes any more?
-They do, yeah.
You know you're making
a rod for your own back
because they're probably gonna ask you
to do all this for them.
Oh, no. For them, no.
But let's see how this goes first.
Let's get my cute little mitts on.
The sooner the cakes are baked…
Right, that's defo done.
…the longer they'll have to cool…
Yeah, she needs longer.
…and the more time for the bakers
to transform their sponges…
Whee! Look at that. Childhood.
…into a spectacular
school fête centrepiece.
So this is gonna be
an old-school computer monitor.
It looks like a screen. It's so good.
-Doesn't it? It does look like it.
-Yeah. So clever.
-The pixelation on that's not bad.
-Maybe I'll take that.
Recreating one of
his most cherished childhood possessions,
Iain's old school monitor
will be filled with raspberry jam
and vanilla buttercream.
Alongside will sit lemon tarts
in the shape of yet another hook-a-duck
and chocolate blocks
filled with shortbread and caramel.
Gonna take this tiny sherbet pip.
I'll put it in
as the heart of the voodoo doll.
-I'll get you some handshakes.
-Wow.
Maybe. Or I could just
flick it at Nataliia.
That'd be more fun, wouldn't it?
Hello.
Bakers, you are halfway through.
Halfway. Okay.
-I've got hockey after school.
-Have you?
-I'll meet you--
-I've got netball.
-See you then.
-I've got my BMX. You can get on the back.
-I'll see you later.
-All right.
That's my macaron.
I'm looking for them to have risen
and a foot around the edge.
Fingers crossed.
The cakes may be cooling…
Oh, that breeze is nice
for cooling those cakes.
…but things are only heating up
for the bakers…
Choux buns in the oven.
…as the race is on
to finish the rest of their displays.
This is like the fiddliest part
of my whole bake.
Maybe I should be a surgeon one day.
-Do you wanna be a surgeon?
-Maybe.
-Maybe?
-Or maybe an anaesthetist.
So you wanna basically drug people
or you wanna cut people up.
Yeah. It's either-or, take your pick.
It's not cooked, it's not cooked,
it's not cooked.
But Jessika can't move forward
until her cake is baked.
It's still in the oven after like an hour.
That sponge should be cooling already,
so I'm really quite worried for time,
and it just means
that everything else is now lagging.
That's so hot.
The proving drawer
was on really, really high.
I'm worried they might be underproved,
but I don't wanna risk
killing all the yeast, so…
My pretzel dough is proved.
It feels really good.
So then I boil them in water,
and then we'll bake them after.
These are gonna be burger buns.
I'll slice them in half,
and stick in my brownie burgers in them.
Oh, they look so real.
You could still go through, babes.
Let's not be silly now, Alison.
Oh, no. Don't be on that downer.
I've seen it before.
Don't give up yet, you know what I mean?
Honestly,
you brighten this tent up, Alison.
Bakers you've got one hour left.
Final hour, yeah. Gonna get it done.
So I'll leave those
as long as possible to kind of dry.
While Aaron…
I'm just gonna have to take her out.
…and Jessika must wait to build
their school fête centrepiece…
I just need to keep going on.
…for the rest of the bakers…
The thud.
…it's the moment of truth.
I feel like it's crunch time now.
I need to shape it
so that it feels
even a little bit like a paddling pool.
This is so fragile. Kind of scares me.
Right, this has to start taking
a little bit more of a shape soon.
It is looking a wee bit sad.
So this is the water.
I've made it a little bit easy for myself.
Trying to make this
look like a paddling pool.
I'm covering my cupcake in fondant.
Or trying to.
This fondant is really messing
with me right now. It's ripping.
You've got this, Iain.
I just hate decorating cakes.
My backpack. This is cool.
Too cool for school.
Oh, I wish this would stay up.
I'm not feeling good.
It's not gonna be the best.
-We have a pie. I'm in my happy place.
-Are you?
Cutting and sticking and making.
-This is what you like, isn't it?
-I love it.
-Go big or go home.
-Go big or go home, yeah.
-Good luck.
-Thank you.
Go big or go home.
Making Derek come to life
like a little bit more.
I'm rushed time-wise. All I can do is try.
Bakers, you have half an hour left.
You've had four hours.
-How have we done four hours?
-Thirty minutes. Stressful.
I mean, they've risen. I don't know
what the texture's gonna be like.
Oh, the pressure.
Right, we're demoulding the coconuts.
They really are soft.
Like, that should not be happening.
I'm gonna dip my apples in the glaze.
This one good.
They're too soft. Oh, this is so painful.
So the cake is not cooked.
It is so ridiculously gooey.
So I'm just gonna have to improvise
and just do what I can.
The texture on this macaron
is gonna be off.
I wanted it really crisp and to hold up.
'Cause they are breaking.
Oh, God. Very messy.
I'm filling my tennis ball choux buns
with the strawberries and cream filling.
I'm feeling the pressure,
but I've just gotta keep going.
Bakers, you have ten minutes left.
No!
This has cracked.
I wish this wasn't cracked,
but I wish a lot of things right now.
Putting my whipped ricotta and pâté.
It tastes really nice,
but it looks absolutely vile.
Let's go. Speed icing. My little ducks.
It's there. That's technically a duck.
Is it ready for the ducks?
Bakers, you've got one minute left.
-What the duck?
-I don't have one minute.
I just need to get all these out.
Coconuts have seen
much better days, sadly.
Ooh, yeah. Little bit stressed.
This is so insane.
Done. Finally.
It looks so messy!
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that's fine.
Bakers, your time is up.
Oh, my good Lord.
Please step away from your Showstoppers.
-Well done.
-This is the worst.
Come on, kids.
-Break time.
-It's a long one, weren't it?
-My cake's raw.
-Raw?
Come on, shall we have a hug?
-Yeah. Ah.
-Ah.
It's judgement time for the bakers'
back-to-school summer fête displays.
Tom, it's time for your Showstopper.
I'm gonna come and help you.
Thank you.
Okay, ready?
So, welcome to the science fair.
-Ooh!
That is a Showstopper.
-Wow!
-I love the look of it.
Overall, it's a fascinating display.
So, now what's in this cake?
This is a red velvet cake
with cream cheese buttercream.
-That's a delicious red velvet cake.
-Very good cake. Perfectly baked.
-Mmm.
-It's very moist.
So we've got the petri dish crème brûlées.
Crème brûlée's nice.
It's got a nice texture
considering how thin it is.
Let's have a look at one of these.
The coconut mousse
that has a chocolate genoise sponge inside
that's soaked in a bit of rum.
Did you mean it to be that liquid?
No, so it was a bit of a nightmare
trying to get the chocolate on them.
Flavour's lovely with the genoise as well.
They're clever, them.
Go on, Paul.
First try.
-Thank you, Tom.
-Thank you very much, guys.
-You can play the quoits.
-I'll have a go at that.
-Go right to the sunburst.
-Over the cake.
That's very ambitious.
-He nearly did it.
-Nearly.
I like all of these.
I think they look exquisite.
Just gotta taste good now.
So, remind us what you made this out of.
Sponge cake. I put some orange
and lemon extract in it.
The sponge is lovely.
Just tastes a bit fake.
Bit artificial, isn't it?
I like the shape,
gorgeous little rings here.
I love the pretzel.
I love that savoury rosemary flavour.
Right, hopscotch.
-Neat as a pin.
-Yeah.
Very nice.
Hook the duck.
Hold.
Overall, I think you've done
an amazing job.
It is style… with substance.
Tennis balls are impressive.
The pool looks a bit of a mess
on the outside.
And are the ducks just fondant?
They are just fondant. They are hookable.
-Hook the duck.
-Paul, look the other way, please.
Look over there.
-Give me a hand. Thank you.
-TV magic.
Yes, Prue. Yeah.
So you have lemon and blueberry cake
with a lemon and blueberry
cream cheese filling.
The sponge is baked beautifully.
That's a lovely sponge. Great job.
Okay. Shall we have a look
at the strawberry and cream?
Oh, that's lovely. It's really light.
You've done a good job with those.
Absolutely delicious.
I love the look of these.
Parmesan and rosemary sandwich biscuits.
Mmm.
That's lovely, them. Texture's fantastic.
-Thank you very much, Toby.
-Thank you very much.
There's a lot of added bits.
That, this, this.
-There's a lot of plastic in this.
-There is, yeah.
Let's have a look at the computer.
So it's a funfetti
with vanilla frosting and raspberry jam.
Love the flavour,
but buttercream's gritty.
So, what have we got here
in the chocolate?
Those are little chocolate-coated biscuits
with a smidge of caramel.
It's mostly chocolate,
and very, very sweet.
-And this is?
-Pâte sablée,
some Swiss meringue,
and a pâte de fruits duck.
The pastry's good,
but the meringue is so sweet.
-Yeah.
-Overall, I think you struggled.
It's not as good as I know you can do.
It's a bit flat and it is a bit untidy.
But what's it taste like?
You are so good at flavour, Aaron.
If you'd had more time,
you could've been much neater about it.
Your buns are underproved.
Yeah, it's very doughy.
The shortbread's lovely.
The filling is delicious.
I used peach powder, cocoa butter,
and coconut oil.
-It's really lovely.
-Mm.
-Thanks, Aaron.
-Cheers.
I love the bag, the colour and the design.
-I'm sorry to cut into your bag.
-Oh, my gosh.
This is vanilla sponges
with cream cheese and citrus curd.
Yeah, I love it. Yeah. I think
the curd filling is just zesty enough
with a beautifully soft well-baked sponge.
The biscuit's a crumbly biscuit, nice.
Ganache is good.
I love the apples.
I'm dying to see what they taste like.
The actual texture of it is spot on.
It's delicious with the spice, the apples,
and everything else inside it.
-It's all really, really good.
-Oh, my gosh. I'm so happy.
And it looks good.
You've done a very good job.
I like the height. It looks really great.
I think the whole thing looks charming.
I've made you a coffee and walnut
and chocolate brownies to look like steak.
-I love that.
-It's a nice coffee and walnut.
Both flavours are really good and strong.
And shortbread biscuits, buttercream,
and apple jam in them.
-They're good.
-Very appley.
And I've made meringue lollies
filled with a vanilla buttercream
and lemon curd.
They're well baked, them.
-Nicely piped too.
-Mm.
-Don't tell me you made the sprinkles?
-No, I didn't make the sprinkles.
No one's ever gonna make sprinkles
by hand again.
There's a lot of stuff going on in here.
I particularly like
the look of the burgers.
-Is that bread you've made?
-No, I've made like a doughnut.
-Wow.
-It's doughnuts twice.
Clever. Let's have a look at this.
So I've done a lemon drizzle sponge cake.
It's slightly overbaked.
-Okay.
-The flavour's nice.
The doughnuts are just vanilla doughnuts
with a strawberry glaze.
It's a nice little structure
you've got inside there.
-Strawberry flavour is really fake.
-Yeah, it is. Yeah.
-This is a lemon?
-Lemon dip, yeah.
Lemon curd is wonderful
and it's really sharp.
A nice little sugar biscuit.
Are you gonna eat it like a burger?
Yeah, you've got to.
Oh, yeah.
You've really got to switch your mind
'cause you just expect beef.
Pretty clever.
You've got a good brownie in there.
The whole thing is delicious.
I think triceratops is looking a bit sad.
Overall, I'm a bit underwhelmed
because it doesn't pop.
Yeah.
So I have made for you
a stout cake with a stout caramel
and a milk chocolate whipped ganache.
Mmm.
-Texture's all wrong.
-I know.
It's the flavour I'm not really keen on.
-Not much else there.
-There's a bitterness to it.
Let's have a look at these feet.
Shortbread biscuit with marshmallow
and a cherry and kirsch jam.
I quite like that. I think it probably
needed more bake on the biscuit.
-It's a bit soft.
-Yeah.
-This is the egg.
-It's a chai whipped ganache,
some biscuit, and then
there's an Italian meringue in there.
It's quite strong, that.
I think I'd like that
in very small quantities.
But it isn't.
-Thank you.
-Thanks, Jess.
I love the way it looks.
That was brutal.
A bake like that,
I don't think is redeemable.
Definitely one of the bottom ones
in the Showstopper.
Obviously, I don't want to go home,
but I think I probably deserve to.
What a Showstopper. Twists and turns.
I mean, I was so surprised
with regards to Aaron.
He literally had smashed the Technical,
smashed the Signature,
and this looked smashed.
Unfortunately,
he was in line for Star Baker,
but he's certainly dropped down the order.
On the other hand,
I think Jasmine did well.
Thought the cake was good.
Her finesse is on a different level
though, isn't it?
I mean, look at that piping. Beautiful.
I did like Tom's.
-I think Toby's joined him.
-Toby did well.
-Toby's balls were amazing.
-His balls were--
So I think he's put himself in line
for Star Baker.
Obviously, someone
is not gonna graduate today.
The one I'm most sort of disappointed in
is Iain.
He can bake better than that.
It was three different disciplines,
and, for me, he failed on all three.
-What about Jessika?
-But not just the bake.
It was about
the flavour combinations were wrong.
She was in a bit of danger anyway
coming into today.
I think, on the other hand,
Nadia and Nataliia,
who were in serious trouble,
have both lifted themselves up.
So, unfortunately,
I think it's between Jessika and Iain.
I agree.
All right, listen, it's been great.
I've really enjoyed
being in the staff room,
having a cup of tea with you guys.
It's been wonderful.
Students, you have been brilliant.
And it's nearly home time, but obviously,
I have the best job
of announcing this week's Star Baker.
So this week's Star Baker goes to…
Jasmine.
I told you!
You've gotta go
for your hat trick next week.
Oh, no!
Ah, sadly,
that leaves me with the horrible job.
The baker who is leaving us this week is…
Jessika.
You are stunning.
This was gonna be my last year to apply,
and I feel chuffed
that I made it to the tent.
-I'm gonna miss you so much.
-I'm gonna miss you.
I'm gonna miss you so much.
I've met some incredible,
talented, inspiring bakers.
You guys are gonna smash it.
So, it's not all bad.
-Bad luck, sweetheart.
-I've learnt a lot, so thank you.
The thing I've loved about Jessika
all the way through
is she's very creative,
and she takes risks every single week.
And I think she took a risk too far
this week.
League of her own, baby girl.
Jasmine's done really well.
Back-to-back Star Bakers.
It's crazy.
It's all about consistency,
and that's what it takes
to get to the final.
She is certainly one to watch,
an exceptional baker.
-I don't want Jess to go.
-I know.
It should've been me.
I was 100% convinced that I was gone.
Third time lucky.
Now, I just need to get through
Chocolate Week.